je voulais faire un point avec vous deux
ans après pour savoir si le Galaxy Z
flip 3 est toujours intéressant
qu'est-ce qu'il raconte est-ce qu'il
s'est abîmé est-ce que la charnière
s'est abîmée est-ce que l'écran s'est
fissuré est-ce que tout a explosé est-ce
que il apocalypse ou alors est-ce que
c'est un smartphone qui a bien résisté
dans le temps qui a bien tenu alors je
vous le dis tout de suite je marque 2
ans parce qu'il fallait bien arrondir on
n'est pas réellement à 2 ans j'ai sorti
ma vidéo de test c'était le 20 août 2021
on est aujourd'hui bon je tourne on est
en mars 2023 bon voyez on n'est pas deux
ans on extrapole un peu la durée en tout
cas on va regarder si la tenue le choc
s'il est intéressant il est toujours là
vous voyez il est là il est là il est
toujours là donc bon il est toujours
vivant en tout cas donc on va faire le
tour complet de ce smartphone pour voir
si cette innovation a signé Samsung est
innovation qui dure dans le temps si
vous l'avez pas acheté si vous posez la
question si vous avez des doutes et bien
est-ce que vous avez eu raison de pas
l'acheter ou alors est-ce que vous
auriez pu l'acheter vous l'auriez emmené
loin c'est vraiment ce qu'on va regarder
aujourd'hui puis c'est chouette parce
que jamais fait de vidéo comme ça en me
disant on va prendre le temps on va
regarder vraiment sur une durée longue
c'est un smartphone qui a vraiment été
utilisé c'est la femme qui l'a eu
pendant longtemps et tu avais presque
deux ans qu'elle utilise donc je vais
tout vous dire vous avez tout savoir
comme ça vous saurez si ça vaut le coup
de venir acheter le Galaxy S3 qu'on veut
toujours acheter son packaging 4 ou les
générations qui suivront et d'ailleurs
si un de ces produits vous intéresse pas
le 5 parce qu'il n'est toujours pas
sorti et bien je vous mets les liens
juste en bas dans la description est-ce
que vous êtes prêts allez on y va
ce smartphone il est beau ce smartphone
il est joli ce smartphone c'était le
Galaxy Z flip 3 c'était la deuxième
génération après le Galaxy Z flip qui
était arrivé il y a pas eu d'oser le
flip 2 parce qu'ils sont venus
harmoniser les gammes par rapport aux
etfold où il y a eu un peu plus de
génération donc on a un nom de flip 3
mais en réalité c'était la deuxième
version cette deuxième version elle est
arrivée avec quoi avec un écran de
notification plus grand que ce qu'on
avait par rapport aux etfips c'était pas
très grand pour autant c'est pas
extrêmement grand et si vous venez
regarder par rapport à ce que nous a
proposé au pot il y a pas longtemps avec
son finden de flip on a plus grand écran
à la verticale et bien ce smartphone de
Samsung commence à faire un peu pas le
figure je pense qu'il va falloir que
Samsung aille plus loin avec un écran un
peu plus grand bon ça on le verra plus
tard donc pensez à vous abonner c'est
pas pour tout de suite tout de suite
mais on verra ce qui arrive je pense du
côté de l'été 2023 ok alors pour
l'instant on est à ce smartphone là qui
était très intéressant avec cet écran de
notification qui est plutôt cool pour
autant il y avait cette question de la
charnière est-ce que la charnière c'est
un truc qui fonctionnait bien parce que
c'est un truc durable est-ce qu'elle l'a
maintenu sa promesse voyez ce qu'elle
continue à tenir dans le temps ou pas du
tout est-ce que le design continuer
voyez il y a quelques petits trucs à
venir regarder de ce côté là donc c'est
vraiment l'époque je vais venir regarder
avec vous et la toute première chose
c'est cette question de la charnière
parce que alors on va regarder un peu on
va venir comparer pour essayer de
comprendre un peu ce qui se passe
Samsung nous a mis une charnière qui est
une charnière en U c'est à dire que vous
pouvez venir voir à travers vous voyez
ça fait un espèce de U on peut venir
voir à travers la différence de la
charnière goutte d'eau qu'utilise au pot
qui est le vrai mouette en bord à bord
et absolument aucun jour la grosse
différence qu'on va avoir c'est que sur
le smartphone de Samsung sur les
smartphones de Samsung voyez on va venir
sentir davantage la pliure sous le doigt
alors que je suis pour là sans quasiment
pas quasiment pas pour l'instant quand
même un peu donc il y a une vraie
différence de technologie pour autant
est-ce que la techno de Samsung est plus
intéressante c'est compliqué de venir
dire dans la longévité parce que j'ai
pas eu de smartphone de haut pendant des
années donc je peux vraiment vous le
dire par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ici cette charnière voyez et
bien elle a vraiment tenu le coup alors
elle tient pas aussi bien que le Galaxy
Z flip 4 Galaxy Z flip 4 vous l'emmenez
bout par vous voyez elle elle tient tout
le temps ici c'est un peu différent
c'est à dire que vous voyez là toute
cette partie là il y a rien qui tient
plus peut-être là ça tient pas mais dès
que vous arrivez au-delà de ça ça tire
alors de toute façon soyons très clair
vous allez pas le mettre comme ça
strictement aucun intérêt d'ouvrir son
smartphone comme ça en espérant qu'il
tienne à moins que vous vouliez vraiment
venir repousser les limites et ça ne
sert strictement à rien donc en fait si
vous le mettez en mode Flex c'est-à-dire
comme ça pour venir l'utiliser notamment
en mode photo et bien là ça fonctionnera
ça fonctionnera bien je prends je dois
modifier je me vois coucou c'est
pratique c'est sympa ça marche bien donc
là-dessus il y a aucun problème hop là
je passe en caméra de selfie ici vous
voyez un petit peu moins bien et donc
vous voyez donc ça ça marche bien le
mode Flex il est cool après je peux
venir l'étendre légèrement pour le
mettre comme ça et là vous voyez que la
charnière elle continue vraiment à très
très bien tenir et là elle est pas
complètement ouverte vous voyez
légèrement penché et elle tient très
bien donc il y a aucun problème il y a
une vraie très très bonne tenue du côté
de la charnière là-dessus je dois
reconnaître que vraiment ça me saoule a
vraiment vraiment bien bosser alors là
je vous l'ai montré à la verticale parce
que on regarde les questions de la
gravité vous voyez est-ce que sur le
phénomène de la gravita mettant comme ça
et bien ça va venir tomber tandis que là
je la mets sur le côté donc on a moins
cette question là et bien ça ça
fonctionne vraiment très très bien
regardez une fois de plus comme ça je
peux le bouger faut que j'aille le
pousser légèrement pour qu'il se mette
comme ça et ça vient donc ça tient très
bien aucun problème donc pour moi cette
charnière elle a bien tenue il y a
vraiment cette question de cette
première position légèrement fermée et
vous le voyez comme ça ici voilà faut
savoir tomber mais une fois de plus ça
paraît réellement d'usage là dessus donc
on s'en fout donc pour moi la charnière
là-dessus elle a très bien tenue la
charnière de ce smartphone n'a vraiment
se positionner entre d'un côté le
Samsung Galaxy Z type 4 qui sera pour
moi la plus résistante et qui bougera
absolument pas d'ailleurs je vous ai
fait une vidéo il y a pas longtemps ou
je viens comparer le oppo finden de flip
et le Galaxy 4 allez jeter un coup d'œil
comme ça vous verrez tout et vous
comprendrez réellement la différence
qu'on a au niveau de la charnière donc
regarde c'est flip 3 il vient se
positionner entre la meilleure charnière
du marché en ce moment c'est le Galaxy
S4 et entre le oppo Finlande de flip qui
est pas mal aussi mais où la charnière
va être un poil plus large pas en droit
donc on vient vraiment situer entre les
deux donc ça reste vraiment une très
très jolie charnière et qui je vous dis
quasiment 2 ans après de l'usage avec de
la fermeture et de l'ouverture plusieurs
fois par jour et bien ça tient donc ça
c'est vachement cool donc ça c'est la
première promesse qui est vraiment tenue
par Samsung ici ça s'ouvre ça se ferme
ça pète pas plus de 2 ans après alors je
vous ferai peut-être pas le test 3 ans 4
ans après parce que il faut il faut
passer à autre chose mais en tout cas
voyez quasiment 2 ans après ça tient il
y a pas de souci maintenant il y a un
autre que je voulais savoir avec vous
c'est au niveau du design parce que on
était sur un des nouveaux design de
smartphone donc c'était que la deuxième
génération ici j'ai remarqué un truc qui
à l'écran pour qu'il est forcément posé
sur la face arrière donc voilà il y a
vraiment ce petit truc là ce petit
phénomène alors je sais pas si c'est un
phénomène de décollement parce que si
vous regardez là ça va très légèrement
se décoller en fait vous voyez je passe
mon doigt dessous et en fait ça c'est
décollé donc ça explique pourquoi est-ce
que toute cette partie là est comme ça
donc en fait ce décollement c'est fait
vraiment dans cette partie en partant de
la la mais là au centre c'est pas du
tout décollé alors pourquoi ça s'est
décollé est-ce que c'était un défaut de
fabrication j'en sais rien alors on
n'est jamais venu avec un truc essayer
de lever de le décoller soyons clairs
donc c'est vraiment sur de l'usage mais
ça c'est légèrement des collègues ici
sur le côté bon après est-ce que c'est
un défaut inhérent à ce produit je sais
pas j'ai pas non plus fait une enquête
auprès d'un gros panel de consommateur
qui avait acheté ce smartphone mais en
tout cas sur le produit que j'ai c'est
arrivé est-ce grave maintenant pour
l'usage du produit au quotidien la
réponse est non si ça continue à se
décoller ça poserait un vrai problème en
tout cas pour l'instant c'est comme ça
et ça semble pas évoluer davantage et là
si vous venez regarder la toute cette
partie là en fait il y a pas d'usure qui
qui serait pas normal alors j'ai une
petite marque là sur le côté parce qu'il
a frotté il a pris un petit shoot mais
rien sinon sur le côté de la charnière
j'ai rien de particulier à des petits
frottement pas sur le côté parce qu'il a
vécu fatalement il a dû rencontrer
peut-être des clés ou peut-être qu'il
est tombé un moment ou un autre mais
au-delà de ça pas d'autres problèmes
voyez là il a un petit peu aussi pris un
petit éclat là sur le côté là mais
au-delà de ça il y a pas grand chose et
là ici de ce côté là rien au niveau de
l'écran là externe j'ai pris aucun pet
rien il est très bien très résistant les
optiques aussi c'est pareil peut-être
une micro rayure sur l'écran mais bon
rien du tout donc là dessus aucun
problème c'est résistances ça tient
vraiment ce que tu es à l'arrière en
fait qui a été marqué mais au-delà de ça
sinon c'est l'usure normale sur un
smartphone donc rien ne déconnant je
veux qu'on se parle maintenant de
l'écran externe ce que je vous disais
avant sur le zflip on avait un tout
petit écran de notification tout petit
tout petit et on voit qu'aujourd'hui on
tend aller vers des écrans un peu plus
grands et ce que nous a proposé au point
ils sont finden de flip me paraît
intéressant et me paraît être là où il
faut aller quitter avoir une partie
grande au niveau de l'extérieur autant
venir l'utiliser alors pour autant
est-ce que cet écran de notification
réellement un sens ici alors on le voit
qu'après usage en fait il a un léger
sens c'est-à-dire que pour les appels
téléphoniques faut-il encore avoir des
buzz si vous avez des Galaxy buzz ou des
écouteurs on peut l'utiliser ça pas été
l'usage ici à la maison donc en fait pas
réellement eu besoin de venir passer ses
appels ici tout en sachant que les
fonctionnalités que vous avez là sont
des nouvelles fonctionnalités de one ui
qui ont été implémentées l'année
dernière mais que on n'avait pas au
début donc l'habitude n'a pas non plus
été prise et il faut dire que ma
compagne qu'il a beaucoup utilisé n'a
pas l'habitude de passer des appels avec
des écouteurs donc bon elle a pas du
tout utilisé cette partie là pour venir
passer des coups de fil si ce n'est
éventuellement pour appuyer ouvrir et
passer un coup de fil au-delà de ça non
pas du tout la météo je suis pas
convaincu qu'il y a réellement eu un
usage de cet écran externe là il a été
utilisé surtout pour venir quand on
reçoit un sms tiens je reçois un message
hop je l'ouvre je regarde ce qu'à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment plus ce côté
notification donc si vous recevez un SMS
vous pouvez le voir vous ouvrez vous
pouvez répondre directement si vous
voyez un appel bah vous pouvez l'ouvrir
vous voyez qui c'est vous pouvez soit le
rejeter soit le prendre pareil pour des
notifications de base mais au-delà de ça
pas grand chose alors s'il y a le petit
truc le petit hack au niveau de la photo
vous faites le double tap et vous voyez
en photo là mais une fois de plus le
cadre il est pas fou parce que regardez
là vous voyez ça comme ça vous dites pas
je vois bien mon cadre on va pas bien
son cadre alors ça je l'ai montré à ma
femme il y a pas longtemps parce qu'elle
savait pas il me dit bon ok mais c'est
pas très intuitif parce que on a pas un
cadre qui est ouf donc c'est pas
forcément évident de doit se projeter
là-dessus ça c'est vrai que bon vous
voyez regardez ça vous dites pas ok donc
là je m'imagine sur un 16 9 sur un carré
comment je suis c'est pas très très
évident hop là vous voyez ça a pris une
photo donc bon il y a pas des trucs qui
est vraiment à venir améliorer en l'état
c'est pratique mais c'est pas ouf le
truc qui est vraiment cool par contre
c'est venir l'ouvrir et d'avoir ce grand
écran intérieur avec votre capteur
d'empreinte digitale qui marche toujours
très bien j'ai eu aucun problème
là-dessus il fonctionne bien bon ok ça
roule et puis surtout si vous posez la
question pour revenir très rapidement
sur cet écran externe vous dire en fait
il y avait que sur le zflip 4 que
j'avais le fait de pouvoir passer mes
appels comme ça et bien non c'est une
mise à jour c'est du logiciel donc ce
qui a été déployé sur le zflip 4 est-ce
qu'on a beaucoup montré sur le Netflix 4
existe également sur le zip 3 ça je vous
l'avais déjà dit et alors il y a un
autre truc qui est aussi intéressant à
savoir du point de vue logiciel parce
que là on est sur One uy 5.1 basé sur
l'Android 13 c'est qu'effectivement les
mises à jour ont été poussées sur le zip
3 elle le feront poussé moins longtemps
que sur le Netflix 4 parce qu'il y a un
décalage de génération il y a un an de
décalage totalement donc arrivera un
moment où les mises à jour on les aura
plus mais en tout cas pour l'instant en
2023 vous avez la dernière version de
one URI la 5.1 d'ailleurs je vous ai
fait une vidéo dessus allez jeter un
coup d’œil sur ma chaîne youtube et vous
avez un Android 13 donc on a les mises à
jour de sécurité on a les mises à pour
Android pour l'instant ça fonctionne à
l'intérieur vous avez une grande écran
un grand écran bon on s'en fout de la
diagonale mais ce qui est intéressant
ici en fait ce qui est vraiment
intéressant à venir retenir c'est que
c'est une technologie c'est du dynamique
à molette 2x c'est dynamique à molette
2x vous l'avez encore aujourd'hui dans
les smartphones de Samsung c'est à dire
que si vous allez par exemple sur la
gamme S23 et bien vous avez cette
technologie dynamique à molette 2x donc
pas réellement nouveauté ici donc c'est
toujours la même techno dalle qui marche
très bien qui est super bien très bien
maîtrisé de la pâte Samsung donc ici
elle a pas bougé très bonne techno ça
marche bien l'écran reste très cool très
lumineux donc ici vraiment vraiment ça
fonctionne bien là regardez vous le
voyez sur le côté en fait comme l'écran
est fait bien des petites cochonneries
qui viennent se caler sur le côté alors
vous pouvez venir les enlever soit avec
un ongle vous grattez vous les enlevez
bon c'est pas ouf un petit coton-tige
pas mouillé on évite bien évidemment
vous évitez le cure-dent pour pas venir
rayer tout ça mais là vous voyez vous
avez toutes ces petites cochonneries qui
viennent se déposer sur le côté et ça
c'est la façon dont tu es fabriqué le
smartphone qui fait que on vient
retrouver ça donc c'est pas foufou mais
bon voilà il faut le savoir alors vous
le retrouver quand même tout du long si
on vient se balader vous l'avez même ici
sur le coin au niveau de la charnière là
vous venez plier on vient le retrouver
ici alors est-ce que c'est grave non
est-ce que c'est moche oui est-ce que ça
fait cracra oui ça vous pouvez quand
même vous venir l'enlever très
facilement vous prenez je vous dis alors
peut-être là un petit cure-dent mais on
fait gaffe mais tout ce qui est écran
pas de cure-dent un petit coton-tige sec
ou alors vous pouvez venir gratter avec
votre ongle voyez mais sans trop appuyer
parce qu'il faut surtout faire gaffe pas
venir rayer l'écran ici ça c'est super
important si vous regardez au niveau de
la pluie juste à droite vous allez voir
des petites marques ça c'est des marques
d'usure qui commence à apparaître alors
elles sont très légères elles sont très
fines si j'allume l'écran regardez on
les voit quasiment pas on peut
éventuellement les deviner si je regarde
de l'autre côté de mon smartphone aussi
dans la partie droite et bien j'en ai
également qui sont visibles un petit peu
la voyez sur le côté je commence à voir
quelques petites marques de pliure pour
l'instant ça a pas déconné pour
l'instant ça a pas pété si j'allume mon
smartphone il y a strictement rien qui
est visible mais lorsqu'il est éteint ça
se voit ça se voit vraiment dans la
partie centrale là où vous avez
l'appeler donc je sais pas si dans 2 ans
et demi trois ans on commence à être
alors il est évident que ça commence à
marquer est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
accélération est-ce qu'on aura plus je
peux pas vous le dire tout de suite je
les sens pas sous le doigt je sens
vraiment rien lorsque je toucher comme
ça mais en tout cas lorsqu'il est assez
visible et lorsque je vien gratouiller
légèrement avec mon ongle comme ça je
sens une petite rugosité sous le doigt
vous voyez qui est juste ici là lorsque
je viens insister légèrement et une fois
de plus l'écran allumé je veux
absolument aucune différence donc ça je
pense vraiment que ce sont les premiers
signes d'usure qu'on commence à voir au
niveau de cette pliure avoir combien de
temps ça va tenir alors je vous dis nous
on est un petit peu moins de 2 ans
est-ce que 2 ans et demi 3 ans je sais
pas voilà j'ai pas utilisé pendant assez
longtemps pour vous donner ça c'est un
formateur qui malgré tout reste assez
récent donc vraiment compliqué de venir
se projeter à l'avenir mais je vous dis
une fois de plus pour un smartphone qui
a même pas deux ans bon ça reste
acceptable ça pose une fois de plus la
question du reconditionné de l'occasion
est-ce qu'au bout de trois ans ça va
vraiment se marquer ça va craquer trois
quatre ans ça je sais pas et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de recul
dessus alors tout ça c'est bien
maintenant il y a la question de la
performance qui est intéressante parce
que un smartphone forcément on voit
qu'il a 2 ans il y a eu une nouvelle
génération il y en a encore une qui va
arriver cette année on est sur un
processeur qui est forcément un peu plus
vieux on est sur le standra Gold 888 qui
était présenté en 2020 fin 2020 le stade
dragon 888 qui est un processeur qui est
toujours qui fonctionne bien mais il y a
eu d'autres générations le saint dragon
8 gn1 il y a le syndrome 8 gène 2 je
vous ai présenté tous ces deux
processeurs donc on va se demander
est-ce que c'est un smartphone qui reste
bon en termes de performance et ben oui
ça c'est un truc qui est intéressant
alors attention attention attention
attention c'est pas le smartphone le
plus performant si vous voulez
aujourd'hui plus de performance sur
galaxy Z flip 4 qui a un des derniers
processeurs même si c'est pas le dernier
processeur qui sera un peu plus
performant donc ce qu'il faut vraiment
tenir ici c'est que pour venir faire
tourner toutes vos applications ça
fonctionne regarder lorsque je vais
l'ouvrir lorsque je ferme lorsque je
veux venir naviguer ici ça reste fluide
ça reste clair j'ouvre je pose mon doigt
tac tac ça déverrouille très rapidement
c'est très réactif donc là dessus j'ai
absolument aucun problème pareil lorsque
je vais sur une application lorsque je
vais ouvrir une application lorsque je
veux la fermer ça se lance rapidement
tout est très réactif donc c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui continue à
bien fonctionner aujourd'hui donc en
termes de performance pas de souci si
par contre vous voulez avoir beaucoup de
performances c'est très exigeant sur du
gaming clairement c'est pas là-dessus
qu'on va aller mais pour plein de petits
jeux plein de petites conneries là vous
voyez par exemple j'ai des jeux de mon
fils il fait ses petits jeux là et là
c'est HOT WHEELS l'Ultimate gain genre
ça c'est pour son éclairage il a plein
de petits jeux comme ça ça fonctionne
vous voyez un petit Candy crush saga ça
fonctionne donc tous ces petits jeux là
ils fonctionneront donc pour moi ça
reste un smartphone qui reste malgré
tout actuel et continue à fonctionner
ici le truc qui fonctionne un peu moins
bien et qui est un peu déceptif sur ce
smartphone c'est toute la partie
autonomie on est sur une batterie de
3300 milliampères heure alors c'est vrai
qu'effectivement c'était la deuxième
version Samsung a dû trouver de la place
en terme de design interne pour mettre
la batterie alors c'est de la batterie
double cellule vous avez une batterie
ici vous avez une deuxième partie ici
ils sont venus le faire évoluer avec le
zflip 4 en montant de 3300 milliards à
3700 milliampères parce que déjà mieux
et alors c'est vrai que là ce smartphone
le truc un peu relou c'est l'autonomie
vous le gardez une petite journée il
faut vraiment venir le recharger en fin
de journée parce que vous allez vraiment
commencer à manquer au niveau de
l'autonomie et ça ça peut être
rapidement un poil relou donc il faut le
savoir tout en sachant que une fois de
plus sur le zflip 4 comme vous êtes
compté sur le processeur d'une
génération antérieure et bien on va
avoir une plus grosse batterie un peu
plus d'autonomie donc on vient de
pousser un peu plus loin donc pour moi
il y a pas de différence entre ce que
j'avais au moment où j'ai eu ce
smartphone au niveau de l'autonomie par
rapport à ce que j'ai aujourd'hui on va
regarder la partie photo et vous allez
voir que bon c'était un peu des
reproches que je pouvais faire à ce
smartphone parce que vous avez deux
optiques de 12 mégapixels en grand angle
et un ultra grand-angle mais
des trucs qui n'était pas parfait et qui
sont venus améliorer avec le zflip 4
donc si vous voulez quelques petites
photos pourquoi pas mais vous allez la
regarder c'est vous faire votre propre
idée alors regardez je vous montre parce
que c'est l'heure de différents moments
ça c'est sur le grand angle et l'ultra
grand-angle bon ok ce qu'on va vraiment
venir retrouver c'est ce que tu as un
peu Lens flair que vous avez là vous
voyez la gestion des lumières c'est des
fois difficile on le voit ici là c'est
pareil on vient se balader alors bon
c'est c'est pas mauvais en soi attention
hein mais je trouve que des fois ça
manque la voyait il y a eu un petit zoom
dedans il y a un côté très numérique au
niveau de l'image on le voit
effectivement aussi au niveau de la
personne ici on le voit au niveau de la
voiture et c'est ce côté que je vais
vraiment venir regretter un peu des fois
ça manque un peu de piquer ça manque de
définition l'algo est un peu trop
poussif derrière pour venir récupérer
tout ça là c'est pareil je suis à Road
c'est pas fou bon là ça fonctionnait pas
trop mal c'était éclairé là les lumières
voyez il y a un côté qui est pas ouf ça
me transcende pas là c'est pas une
condition de faible luminosité il a
beaucoup de mal avec les optiques donc
il nous là c'est pareil il y a un zoom
voyons on le voit au niveau du numérique
c'est très numérique c'est pas très très
beau en fait sinon si vous partez sur
grand temps classique et que vous zoomez
pas dedans ça fonctionnera de façon
c'est que du zoom numérique parce que on
a pas de téléobjectif sur ces format là
aujourd'hui les constructeurs ont pas
mis de téléobjectif donc je vous dis
c'est grand-angle ultra grand-angle donc
bon là c'est pareil vous voyez c'est ça
a été zoom c'est très très numérique
c'est ce que je viens de reprocher il
aurait fallu un 48 mégapixels alors pour
faire un peu plus de choses quand vous
commencez à zoomer numérique dans un 12
mégapixels clairement le taf il se fait
pas donc bon voilà on regarde très
rapidement mais voyez la qualité elle
est pas folle folle c'est pas dégueu
mais c'est pas foufou la voyez par
exemple les éclairages c'est pareil il a
du mal il a du mal là et c'est un peu
globalement ce que je vais reprocher là
les hautes lumières aussi un peu de mal
on le voit voyez ici là c'est toute
cette question qui est pas très très
bonne faible luminosité dans un dans un
resto toujours les optiques là qui
déconnent un peu là le lance flair qu'on
a ici bon voilà c'est vraiment un peu la
limite regarder là vous voyez tout ce
truc là qui est très joli j'ai fait à
peu près les mêmes photos avec le Galaxy
S23 ultra et jeter un coup d’œil vous
verrez sur mon test photos c'est beau ça
déconne pas alors ça peut être le même
capteur on est sur un 200 mégapixels on
va se calmer c'est pas du tout la même
histoire mais pour autant vous voyez
c'est pas fou là c'est pas rien regardez
là il tout ce côté un peu luminosité qui
va un peu baver ici qui est pas très
bien maîtrisé et voilà c'est vraiment
tout ce côté là que je vais venir
reprocher là c'est pareil l'autre
lumière bon ça pique un peu par moment
c'est pas très bien défini alors on peut
faire des choses on a des jolies
souvenirs vous voyez là c'est pareil là
il y a l'autre lumière au fond il a un
peu de mal mais dans l'ensemble ça te
permet d'avoir des photos des bonnes
photos pas dégueu mais sur un smartphone
à 1000 balles quand il est sorti
regardez même c'est pareil il a le
soleil là c'est pas ouf je trouve qu'il
ça m'a envoyé il y a un truc on se dit
ah là vous voyez c'est pareil là c'est
pas c'est pas ouf ça reste un peu flou
flou là donc peut-être que c'était un
mode portrait qui a été déclenché à ce
moment-là mais vous voyez on n'est pas
sur ce qu'on attend d'un smartphone dans
le très haut de gamme en terme de
photographie et c'est vraiment le
reproche que je venais faire moi sur ce
zip 3 je trouve que ça a été corrigé en
partie sur le zflip 4 même s'il restera
encore des choses à venir améliorer vous
voyez les zones numériques il est
dégueulasse alors c'est mon fils qui
s'est fait plaisir avec des animaux mais
bon voilà donc je vous montre rapidement
effectivement il y a pas grand nouveauté
hein c'était ce qu'on avait vu à
l'époque mais en termes de photos on
pourrait s'attendre à mieux on arrive à
sortir des choses mais si vous voulez
faire de très jolies photos et bien il y
a un moment on reste un petit peu sur
enfin sur ce Samsung Galaxy Z flip 3
maintenant qu'on a fait un peu le tour à
360 sur ce les différents points que
j'ai vu chose que j'ai identifiées et
que je voulais venir vous montrer la
question c'est est-ce que ce Galaxy Z
flip 3 est toujours intéressant
aujourd'hui en 2023 est-ce que ça vaut
le coup de venir l'acheter alors la
réponse ça va être une fois de plus ça
dépend c'est que c'est j'aimerais bien
trancher des fois des trucs mais ça va
dépendre ça va surtout dépendre de vous
et ça va dépendre du tarif auquel vous
allez le trouver ce smartphone quand il
est sorti le coûtait 1059 €, il est
évident que si vous le trouvez aux
alentours de 900 et des boîtes euros
c'est pas intéressant parce que le tarif
auquel vous allez pouvoir venir trouver
le Galaxy Z flip 4 qui reste quand même
un peu cher tout en sachant et je pense
cette année va t'arriver un Galaxy Z
flip 5 en tout cas une nouvelle
génération donc je suis pas convaincu
que ça vaille vraiment le coup de venir
poser presque 1000 balles sur ce
smartphone aujourd'hui non si par contre
vous le trouvez un tarif qui va venir se
rapprocher tout doucement des 600 500
600 euros pourquoi pas du reconditionné
vous voyez en occasion il est tenu alors
après il faut venir voir effectivement
si vous avez pas eu ces problèmes qui
sont c'est venu se décoller à l'arrière
vérifier l'état et why not donc si vous
le trouvez dans reconditionnez plus que
d'occasion parce que de l'occasion c'est
du particulier à particulier il y a pas
garantie donc c'est toutefois il y a un
petit défaut pour être un peu embêté
mais sur du reconditionné je dirais
pourquoi pas ou si vous le retrouvez en
neuf à un tarif qui est vraiment
beaucoup plus bas je retourne 600 balles
ça ça me paraît pas mal si vous le
trouvez plus cher pour moi on y va pas
on va regarder plutôt le Galaxy Z flip 4
ou pourquoi pas on va attendre que le
nouveau sorte à la fin de l'année venir
là-dessus en tout cas ce que j'ai
vraiment retenir ici et ce qui
m'intéresse quand on a vu arriver cette
innovation on s'est dit est-ce que ça va
tenir est-ce que la charnière va tenir
est-ce que l'écran va se fissurer est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des problèmes ou pas et
bien la réponse est non alors attention
non on le pondèrent légèrement on voit
qu'effectivement et bien alors ça dépend
peut-être de ce modèle là la charnière
elle vit être un peu moins résistante là
mais pour tout ce qui va être usage
absolument aucun problème j'arrive pas à
me souvenir c'est quand je l'ai utilisé
même en regardant mes différents tests à
ce moment-là est-ce que j'avais ça à ce
moment-là ou pas j'arrive vraiment pas
le revoir mais en tout cas sur toute la
question usage tenue et solidité
robustesse pour moi il y a pas de sujet
la charnière elle fait le taf l'écran
voit qu'il commence un peu à s'user sur
les côtés mais on est à quasiment deux
ans donc est-ce que je vais pouvoir
venir l'emmener beaucoup plus loin
est-ce que je vais pouvoir venir pousser
trois ans quatre ans pourquoi pas ce que
je vous conseille c'est que si vous
venez l'acheter en reconditionné vous
venez vraiment regarder dès le départ si
vous voyez un peu d'usure au niveau de
l'écran vous demandez éventuellement un
soit le retourner soit faire réparer
parce que si on commence vraiment avoir
une usure un peu trop marquée c'est là
où ça peut être un peu déconnant mais je
vous dis quasiment deux ans après pour
moi il y a pas de souci et ça fonctionne
donc ça c'est cool ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle donc cette charnière elle est
bonne l'écran il est bon je crois qu'il
était certifié plus de 300000 pliages
donc clairement pour moi ici alors j'ai
pas compté on n'a pas compté sur
quasiment 2 ans et 300000 pillages mais
voyons on peut y aller un paquet de fois
et là-dessus pour moi ça déconne pas on
peut venir les faire donc on a un truc
qui est bien un truc qui résistant donc
oui ce smartphone reste actuel oui si
vous voulez acheter neuf à un tarif
intéressant ça vaut le coup oui si vous
le trouvez en reconditionné et qui ne
l'a pas ce petit défaut à l'arrière et
que vous n'avez pas de démarque au
niveau de la pliure vous pouvez y aller
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai à vous dire
maintenant si vous pouvez attendre un
peu et que vous voulez attendre encore
quelques mois vous verrez peut-être que
le zip 4 va être moins cher et que ça va
être intéressant ou alors pourquoi pas
elle fait 3 encore moins cher dans la
deuxième partie de l'année puisque vous
aurez potentiellement à zip 5 qui
devrait arriver donc c'est chouette donc
pour moi le truc a vraiment retenir
c'est que cette innovation elle
fonctionne elle s'inscrit dans le temps
ça me saoule à bien travailler il reste
sérieux il est résistant on peut faire
confiance en tout cas de ce que j'envoie
moi aujourd'hui au smartphone pliable de
Samsung en tout cas ce que je vois ici
sur le zflip 3 après un usage normal
quotidien pendant plus d'un an et demi
ça marche sans aucun problème donc c'est
un oui et c'est un grand oui d'ailleurs
vous est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un
smartphone comme ça pliable est-ce que
vous avez rencontré des problèmes oui
non quoi comment marquer le moins dans
les commentaires et puis au final est-ce
que ce Z flip 3 vous l'avez acheté si
oui est-ce que vous en êtes satisfait
est-ce que vous avez de retour est-ce
que vous avez acheté un Z fold zedfall
de 4 un fold d'ailleurs quand il est
sorti marque ça dans les commentaires je
suis très curieux de voir si c'est un
truc qui a marché chez vous chez moi ça
marche et donc ça c'est un smartphone
que fatalement je peux venir recommander
et une fois de plus s'il vous intéresse
je vous mets tous les liens en bas dans
la description vous connaissez
l'histoire voilà on reparlera très
bientôt de Samsung il y a pas d'actu qui
arrive ça c'est une très très jolie
chose et puis de plein d'autres marques
et de plein d'autres choses donc ça
c'est cool je vous embrasse d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
des bisous Ciao
[Musique]